this is very casual so I don't even care
we could record right now it's recording
now and we'll put that up so this is
very casual and I'm gonna ask you a lot
of questions and if you don't want to
something just say it but uh oh I will
yeah it's very casual what's going on
you're Randy right yeah ask me so I I'm
a fan of your guys product and typically
I own it I have my own my own gym
downstairs I I do research on the
businesses that we talk to and the
people we talk to but in this case I
didn't do too much research on purpose
because I only have the product as a fan
of the products perspective and and I
wanted to come from that point of view
but do you know do you know what this
podcast is and who we are or anything
like that
well give me a little more background
because I'm yeah I've been doing a fair
number of these since this crazy-making
period took off and it's hard to keep up
with them it was funny because I love to
support right because I do so much in
the entrepreneurial community I love to
support young entrepreneurs so I'm I'm
basically you know taking pods that I
normally wouldn't take just because it's
you know we're here we're home and if I
can support other guys that are getting
stuff going that I'm all about it and
what you said you've been doing a lot
since the making what MIT what are you
talking about well I said since this
mayhem right yeah I mean I I do a quite
a lot of stuff in the press normally
just to promote you know to promote my
brand but since we've all been locked at
home there's a massive proliferation of
digital content in the form you know
sometimes in the form of video blogs and
podcasts and so I in fact I just got off
another another one with a with a
investment bank an industry panel
basically but it was just a call so I I
didn't have to be as pretty as I am now
for you Sam good well you look great so
let me we're gonna I'm gonna give you a
20 second or two minute background and
then we're gonna make this all about you
but so i'm sampar i own this company
called the hustle and what we do is i
started it we just turned four years
like a weeks ago so typically we have
these conferences there were be hosts
trade shows conferences where we host
tens of thousands of people each year
but we also have the hustle and the
hustle is our daily email it goes up to
millions of people so millions of people
log in and they get our news from us and
their email INBOX each morning and it's
a great business it's a eight-figure
wonderful business that we bootstrapped
and then we also have trends and trends
KO it's our subscription product so we
it's those premium content community
which is also great business so awesome
and and we do this podcast as a that I
think I forget how many listeners we
have but we've had millions millions of
listens all over a million lessons and
what this podcast kind of started as was
me and Sean my co-host who isn't here
right now but we both have started
companies and we always had these
interesting brain storms with people
like you who were our friends and we
would just riff on interesting ideas and
on cool insights and most people don't
have access to those types of people and
so we just do this publicly and so
that's what we're gonna do today and so
what I want to do right now is uh I want
to learn up a little bit about your
background and kind of how you came to
be where you are now and where you are
now well uh where I am right now is in
my house in Mill Valley I'm sort of like
I feel like Rapunzel I spend all my time
up in the tower above my garage right
it's a become my sort of everything from
the sports marketing department or
sponsorship marketing department of TRX
to the you know production studio for
every one of our sort of you know blog
interactions and that kind of thing but
um you know I I so I'm the founder of
TRX I I live in in you know Marin County
prior to TRX I was a Navy SEAL for 14
years and uh actually created the first
cornice while I was at the special
missions unit and then just decided you
know after I left the SEAL Teams I went
to business school at Stanford and
decided while I was there that this was
a viable business concept you know which
I think at the time I massively over
over as
made it how easy it would be because the
product was so great but what i used
stanford is basically an incubator
second year as an incubator for this
concept and TRX is i guess this is our
15th year in the market and you know
we're doing pretty well we're one of the
only truly global Fitness brands and we
you know we've we've put close to
350,000 training pros through our our
terrace coach qualification courses and
we're in about I don't know somewhere
between fifty and seventy thousand gyms
and studios around the world
most of which are closed right now which
is an interesting you know experience
but fortunately for TRX we we we were
for 10 years all b2b just serving
athletes training centers clubs trainers
and and boutique studios and then about
four or five years ago now we decided
all right we're ready to start to expand
into the consumer the true b2c consumer
space and you know it's good that we did
that because obviously that side of our
business in the co19 environment is
absolutely off the charts the commercial
side of our business is really
struggling because all the all the gyms
and all the trainers are all out of work
so it's been a little bit of A Tale of
Two Cities over the last couple months
but that's basically the snapshot of you
know what TRX is and and I'm today I'm
co-chairman and really promoter in chief
of the brand do you own the company or
have you guys been acquired or anything
like that well the company is we have
you know I raised a long time ago I mean
it raised a bunch of rounds of angel
money when I started and then and then
took on private equity back in 2012 and
then recently recapped the business to
exit those initial partners and bring in
some new partners because that's one of
the you know the dirty little secrets
about institutional capital is once you
take it it's very difficult to get rid
of so so it's a you know it's a private
company but it's co-owned by
by a bunch of us including the capital
partners that that came in got a twenty
at the end of 2018 beginning at 2019 how
much would you raise from the angel
folks well in the way back I think I
raised about Oh to think back to my
round five million bucks from you know
in several rounds of angel money and and
that's great capital right for I don't
know I don't know what the complexion of
your viewership is but think about
raising don't use you can use jargon
it's a very it's a very highly
intelligent not beginner audience so go
ahead yeah well I mean that by far the
highest may look the cheapest source of
of money to grow business as always what
they call non deluded capital right and
and that mostly in the form of sales but
if you're gonna take on diluted capital
the I think by far the best source is
angel investors for a couple reasons
I mean if presuming you pick your angels
the right way because what you get in an
angel investor if you've chosen well is
you get somebody who has a lot of domain
relevant domain expertise because angels
tend to invest in things that they know
and think that one way or another they
can contribute value to if you pick the
right angel you'll get somebody who not
only has domain expertise but super
passionate about your venture generally
angels are willing to to invest on a
common stock basis which you know I
strongly recommend to entrepreneurs that
they stay away from preferred structures
up until they're ready to to sell a
significant piece of their of their
equity or exit all together is what you
once you you know once you bring in a
preferred layer of equity into the cap
stack everything's different in terms of
the Solidarity that you once had
right across the team and the investors
because that changes and and it's a you
know it's it's a tough change in the
variants of most people that I know to
manage so so I'm a big fan of angel
investors in which you get not only
capital right but you end up getting pro
bono experts effectively who are excited
to be involved in your venture how how
big was the company when you sold it to
PE or sell parts to PE well it's been
you know two rounds of that now right so
so the first the first money we took and
I think we're around I don't know you
know 30 million something like that
revenue in annual revenue yeah and and
you know and and who knows you know will
be will be north of you know probably
north of 60 somewhere who knows how far
because kovat is a interesting
experience but and we don't you know we
don't really get into specifics because
we're privately held company so if
you're heading that way just to redirect
you well so you already said it's the
ballpark is sixty million it could be
way higher but you bet a number that's
been said um a company like TRX you guys
so we talked to a lot of like these
direct-to-consumer folks which you
didn't start out as but you are
definitely are now yeah when I think of
TRX I think that you guys are in the
same category as a CrossFit or and this
isn't an insult but like Tony Horton
like you guys are like a brand right
like you're not just some amazon you
don't rank on Amazon and that's how you
win TRX is something that people know
and it's a brand do you think that your
valuation is significantly we you're
multiples be significantly higher
because of that you think or is it still
rough to get a high valuation on
products like this well I mean so for
starters I mean we aren't we aren't it
we're the number one selling fitness
item on Amazon yeah but but I didn't
mean like your weight your path of
success has not been like well we're
just gonna rank higher like it was just
like people love it no I know yeah we
built
I mean look from day one this was never
intended to to be a gift get-rich-quick
scheme right it wasn't a
a trend I mean it's funny because when I
first started the business there were no
predecessors to the product that I
brought to market right our initial hero
product which was the Suspension Trainer
the the idea there seemed kind of crazy
to bring this strap into the club
landscape full of machines and think
that you were gonna be successful but
one of the things that we did that was
that was a really great choice and I
made plenty of less than great choices
but the one of them that was a great
choice was really finding this sweet
spot
in helping training pros of all kinds
right from from chiropractors and
physical therapists on one hand out to
to MMA coaches and powerlifting coaches
on the other end and then obviously you
know and under the under the bell curve
you know tons of personal trainers and
group fitness instructors we decided
we're gonna become the part the business
partner of them and that we were gonna
give them this great tool that had it's
like I was described the suspension
trainer like a magic wand right if you
if you know the magic you can really
make you can become a magician to your
to your clients and your athletes and
deliver them unbelievable results that
always you know you look at a 12 feet of
nylon webbing ago yeah what can that do
with the right Pro and the right
knowledge in that pros head you end up
going oh my god this thing I've never
seen anything like this right and that's
that's a unique characteristic that not
many products or services ever have
which is you have people to come in with
a very low expectation and leave with a
very high level of astonishment and so
that's been a powerful benefit to us and
then we diversified the book the the
company's scope of operations we became
you know the largest provider of
professional education to trainers and
then we brought in the product line
significantly all the while focusing on
this premium brand that you alluded to
which I do believe brings you know and
enhanced multiple the reality though is
that long
if all a company wants to be is a
product company right that delivers
durable goods because our stuff lasts
for freaking ever you know way too long
from Yodo I've had the same on I've had
the same one for four years I think I
got it was gifted on Christmas and I've
had the same one for four years now yeah
I mean and that's and you're in four
years is nothing for a one-on-one right
I I talk to people that are that are
still traveling around using our like
first gen strap from 2005 in their bag
you know and it's I mean on one hand
it's a compliment on another it's a
nightmare right because you need what
they called plan planned obsolescence
yeah yeah the break after like you know
five thousand push-ups we never we never
planned that because I really wanted to
be I look I I came at this whole thing
you know I started my entrepreneurial
career at 39 so after a career as a as a
Navy SEAL so I you know I had a set of
premium level delivery and if I was
gonna be associated with this brand and
that's what we were gonna do so we built
everything that way the unintended
consequence is the one that you and I
are beating around right now is your
stuff lasts forever and that which means
that you know you either have to create
more products to serve your existing
customers which is expensive right as
R&D is not cheap or you have to
constantly be in search of new customers
which is not cheap and so you know it's
it's I think that's why pure product
goes get uh what I would say you know
unfair valuations relevant or relative
to some of these fakers more fake
companies that are you know tech based
companies that have the potential not
the promise but the potential to scale
infinitely right and so those kinds of
companies tend to get higher valuations
than gear companies and that's that's
just one of those realities and it's
part of what you know we've never
planned to be just the gear company we
we have always planned to expand our
services into subscription services and
con
and that's what we've done so let's talk
about that in a second but first right
now you guys make what are your revenue
streams your revenue streams are coming
straight from the revenue streams our
purchases from coaches and things like
that
well coaches and chiropractors and who
like you know B to beat people with
servicing clients right we make well
we're an omni-channel distributor so you
know on the on the commercial side of
the business which is the b2b side yeah
we sell the gym so geared to gyms
services and education to gyms and
trainers yeah but and that's what I want
to ask about what is education so you
well yeah so we knew so we we became
early on I mean if you think back nobody
knew how to use a strap that didn't
stretch and didn't have any weight
attached to it
so if I was with you or one-on-one I had
almost a hundred percent close rate in
the in the earliest days problem was I
can't be everywhere right so and if I
wasn't with you and you were just
looking at a picture of it say on the
website the conversion would drop to you
know five percent so that was something
that I realized very early all right
well I have to be able to scale my
knowledge on how to use this thing and
so I brought in a guy who was introduced
to me very very early in the company's
history again in Frayser Quelch who had
been a career trainer and had written a
lot of education in the form of courses
for other pros right to teach other pros
the various skills I mean how's a
trainer or coach learned his or her
craft they usually get a basic
certification from a entry level
certification body like American Council
on exercise or or NASM or NSCA
and then they go out into practice and
they start developing practical skills
and along the way they want to learn
more about you know a particular tool or
a methodology or and so they they do
they have continuing education
requirements right just like a doctor or
a lawyer they have to they have to do so
many continuing education units per year
to maintain their basic certification we
became one of the
leading providers of those CEC courses
that that help help a new trainer or
coach move toward mastery so do charge
them for I'm on your website now and
that cost money yeah yeah our normal our
knowing we have about ten courses
different kinds and an hour all b2b and
the P not $89 well know traditionally
they were two hundred ninety five right
so two hundred ninety five bucks for a
one day qualification course and it was
eight hours live in person what you're
probably seeing now is we've done some
some pretty incredible pivots with Kovan
nineteen hitting and changing the
landscape and so one of the things we
did early on was try to figure out hey
alright number one we're not gonna be
able to provide education right as long
as this thing lasts because you can't
get people together number two most of
the people who come to our courses are
out of work and so what what what can we
do to support them was sort of idea
number one and then number two was how
do we take this moment which is really a
bunch of lemons being thrown at us and
make lemonade out of it and we decided
that well we can take our courses we can
make them free figure out how to how to
deliver them through zoom instead of
live and we'll do that as long as as
this you know crisis continues and we'll
just try to fill our bucket with a whole
bunch of new pros of all kinds of
stripes right who on the other side of
this will then appreciate that that we
help them out when they were down and
also just grows the community grows the
TRX community and so that's what we've
been doing so then you guys have revenue
from selling the the main product the TR
the main TRX which it looks like you
have a few varieties but I imagine most
is from the main one and then you make
revenue from these hundreds of tuner 100
to 300 dollar b2b digital products what
what's the breakdown is like is the
actual product eighty percent of sales
oh it's you know it's falling pretty
pretty fast as
as the education and now the with what's
the big epiphany and the big unlock
that's gone on over the last two months
is that we massively accelerated our
what already was a migration toward
digital delivery and subscription models
and so you know we've also got an app
that that we make money off of that's a
four ninety-five a month app that
supports the end user and and we we have
turned off the paywall on that during
kovat but that will go back on once
everybody gets back to work you know
we're really using Cova 19 as an
opportunity to develop new to solidify
the relationships with our existing
customers and bring new customers into
the tribe through a free door that
eventually obviously everybody knows
that no business can keep their services
free forever but in the meantime we're
using it as as a big opportunity to you
know to build a new relationship so the
the mix is is really changing the other
thing that that I think you know well
what was the big pre kovat you know I
mean it's probably probably 70/30
between you know equipment but you're
defining equipment way too narrowly
right you're looking at our hero
products which are the suspension
trainers we do the entire ecosystem of
functional training so from yeah you
know steel echo systems that you built
the infrastructure that you know they
not only hang straps on but you fill
with kettlebells bands balls you do
pull-ups on right everything you would
see in a gym yeah you're right
yeah which I which I've used do you have
a sales team to handle that like did you
have to do like hand-to-hand combat for
that or is a lot of it inbound and
you're just fulfilling orders
um it's some of both right I mean no I
don't think any business it certainly
doesn't exist for very long as as all
inbound flow right general you have to
be out there knocking down the you know
the targets yeah I mean but are you like
running paid ads to them or do you
actually have to have a sales force
who's hitting the phones and
mechana hello both yeah both we
advertise into the commercial landscape
through the traditional you know means
to reach gym owners and trainers but
then we also have a pretty significant
direct sales force inside and outside
that that does account development
service say look I'm looking at um I use
this tool that guesses website traffic
if I looking at this tool I would
imagine that your sales are like Forex
in April what they were in February it
looks like you guys are just like like
you your web traffic has gone through
the roof yeah well it certainly has and
the reason is I think less to do with
anything we've changed in our marketing
then with the reality that you know as a
ten year into B business we we've put
you know we serve tens of millions of
people around the world who identify
themselves as TR extras but ironically
had never bought a product for their
home right because they use us Jim and I
run into people constantly one of my
best friends you know will tell me like
oh I've never bought you know call me
and be like hey can you give me a
friends-and-family yet you know discount
and I'll be like you don't have one of
our straps these are people that I know
are diehard TR Xers and then there would
be like hello man I do it three times a
week in the gym you know and so that
that was that was a reality that comes
with being a b2b business for ten years
but what happened with the virus was
when all the gym doors got shut all the
sudden all of those installed that
installed base of TR Xers went well how
the hell am I gonna do my my workouts
and so they turned to our Amazon site
and our web site and you know that's
that's been I believe the big source of
of the the growth the explosive growth
you have a unique advantage of seeing
like consumer goods or well hard goods
and digital products
so you're able to see how they both work
and my from my perspective and I've been
an investor and I have friends who sell
direct to consumer hard goods and then I
also have a digital company and I've
invested in them as well what my
perspective is that the DTC guys can
grow their revenue from zero to not zero
very quickly but there's massive supply
chain headaches where as digital it's
often the opposite where it's maybe a
little more challenging to get started
but the margins are way better and you
never have a supply chain issue what uh
knowing both sides of the business which
do you prefer well I mean I I think did
which do I prefer I prefer the one
that's easier and makes more money um
you know I think with what's that yeah
well the reality is that I think I think
creating a digital company pure digital
is is hard because it's a very cluttered
field right it's a it's there's
especially now I mean this this virus
has unleashed the digital universe right
and so now just like any other
marketplace there's gonna be this
explosion of would be you know
participants and then there will be a
consolidation and and some of the you
know they'll separate sort of the wheat
from the chaff and I think that we're in
a really unique position because we
started as a physical products company
then we became an education company
education and content right because we
made I mean he'll we probably did 35
DVDs prior to DVDs becoming
disintermediated by digital delivery
we've obviously taken all that content
and repurposed it into our digital echo
systems but then we we became a brand
like a really significant premium brand
in the space and then we stretched that
brand around the world so now we're in a
really unique position because we have
the best of both worlds right we have a
large customer base that bought our
physical gear and that then came to
group classes in clubs around the world
that we helped develop and and educate
the instructors who are do
those so it got comfortable and
identified with our brand and then as
we've done more and more consumer
branding we've extended that brand from
the the pro space which is great from a
credibility standpoint because if
trainers and physical therapists love
you the consumer at home tends to go
well these guys must be you know a
quality operation and so now we're in a
really unique position now we're turning
on some new digital engines and
subscription engines that give us the
best of it all right we're you will have
our products which you're right you
stock out of I mean we're you know we've
stocked out over and over and over
during this thing because no one plans
for a you know multi time step function
change in the demand curve right and you
you you scramble to try to catch up to
it and I think a lot of us will find
ourselves just about the time where
we're caught up and we've got this you
know a whole new stockyard full of
product maybe the demand will settle
down a little bit and we'll end up with
Harry yeah and it's but that's just
that's part of being a physical product
you know just supplier is so so that's
my question which one do you find which
one do you personally enjoy more both in
terms of working on and the results I'm
a uh I mean I'm an inventor you know so
so that is part of my like it's it's a
it's probably what maybe want to go into
the Navy SEAL Teams I have a MacGyver
bent to me and I came up with an old man
that can fix literally anything with
almost nothing and so I I sort of grew
up you know out in the garage until you
know the middle of the night holding a
flashlight for my oh man well he was you
know jerry-rigging some kind of a of a
fix to to a old motor or to what ever
could be anything so I really enjoy a
lot of time and energy at TRX developing
our next products I also though
appreciate and enjoy creating great
content whether it's in the form of pro
education or whether
the form of end-user content a workout
content and so I I would say I like both
I like the economics of the digital side
of the equation for the reasons that
you've pointed out right you don't stock
out of it and you don't it scales
infinitely but I don't think that it's
an easy business to just say oh I'm
gonna become a digital content publisher
and I'm gonna you know make a billion
dollars yeah like you and the other
billion would be digital content
producers that are out there all right
on the same path and so so I I like them
both
I like the multiples on digital content
and subscriptions though I'll tell you
that so I'm gonna ask you about some I'm
gonna ask you about that in a second and
I'm gonna ask you about interesting
ideas that you're seeing it in new
opportunities but first you said
something that you're the chairman right
so does that mean you're not the CEO
yeah I'm what we brought in a a
president you know I've tried a number
of times to get out of the day day in
day out management of the organization
because a couple reasons one at this
point you know I mean number one there's
one founder right and so you've got a
certain amount of founder cachet that is
really valuable in working with the
press and working with key accounts
right in in generating love around the
brand that there aren't others who can
do that there are others who can manage
the steady state sort of linear growth
of a you know of a midsize and and
growing company in fact there's those
that can do that better than me because
I'm more of a startup guy so I've tried
you know several times over the last
call it six years to to get more out
into the market and less in the
conference room and you know we hired a
president about eight months ago who you
know I've been doing a transition where
I can you know basically hand most of
the day and day out over
him and to you know to to to the team
and then with our new partners they're
very good at the financial engineering
side of the equation so I'm not right
that ain't I mean that is just not
something that turns me on
I like the outcome but the process is
just not something that you know floats
my boat and everybody's everybody's cut
a different cloth so what I'm really
focusing my energy on is promoting the
brand developing your products and and
looking at new initiatives right that's
something that I'm I'm very good at and
passionate about is sort of trying to
see around the corner and what what the
next opportunities gonna be for the
brand we're very similar so I've done
the same thing I have a president who
handles a lot of stuff and I do the
exact same thing where I can lead vision
but I also come at the very bottom and I
could just change pixels and invent I do
it digitally but the same exact crap
where I'm just I have my computer up
late at night I'm just making stuff and
most of it sucks but every once in a
while I'll show to someone and they're
like oh yeah let's go make that that's
the product patient dilemma right most
of it most of it goes nowhere but but
about every 10 you know every every
tenth effort you go oh wait a minute
there's something to this one right and
that's you know and that's you got to be
wired to not get frustrated by that just
like you know just like folks who like
to manage it that mid level they don't
like the scariness and the ambiguity and
the you know the vagaries of of the
startup or creator they like the the
consistent predictability of you know
weekly staff meetings in a checklist and
all the things that make me sort of you
know make the hair stand up on the back
of my neck because I feel like man this
is not where I want to be so this and
this is a consistent pattern that we've
seen I don't know if you know this woman
named Sophia Amoruso but she had this
company called Nasty Gal and it's scale
to I forget the exact number one or two
hundred million a year in sales and had
multiple offers around half a billion
and it they screwed it up for a bunch of
reasons one of the biggest ones that she
was like I'm a brilliant at creating
I'm horrible at operating and I I to him
like that where I'm brilliant at
creating but operating I just don't find
it to be exciting and I think that most
people who start stuff are the same way
but I think there's actually a huge
issue in your in Silicon Valley although
you may or may not run in the Silicon
Valley crew particularly amongst that
group of people I've noticed there's a
huge problem of people starting stuff
who are afraid to hire people to
actually run the thing and what I've
really embraced and it took years to
learn this is that there's actually
people who like creating the car from
scratch and designing it and then
there's people who love modding it out
and making it better
and having both is really important how
did you hire your president and what was
that like going through that process and
also how many mistakes have you made in
hiring their own people because that's
exciting yeah plenty I mean I mean look
first of all so I I operated the company
you know every single day for its first
10 years that's a long time right and at
that point when you're winning it the
engine of both creation activation
aligned with why not in your three I
mean well because we were still very
much evolving right and I think one of
the challenges with
bringing in somebody to take over the
daily management is you have to be
pretty well-defined about where you're
headed as an entrepreneur before you can
now hand the wheel to somebody right if
you're wheeling right wheeling left
that's not exactly the moment to be like
hey buddy here take this right because
them guys like where do I Drive man so
so I think that's the answer the short
answer is I wasn't ready yet
in terms of our our definition - and the
enough certainty to the general
direction of our course to want to hand
that over but about your eight I was
nice okay so I handed it over the first
probably the first two presidents that I
hired which are both great guys but the
mistake that that I made largely from
being from listening to my then private
equity partners that you know had had
sort of their their business school 101
playbook they were trying to run which
is go hire a quote unquote best practice
president well okay help me kill me kill
me yeah I'm sure I was just gonna say
I'm sure you're gonna you're gonna be
hearing something familiar here right
which is that a lot of the institutional
capital investors they they they haven't
run businesses themselves so they want
to execute what they learned in Business
School which is you know the idea of
best practice well what is best practice
that's the problem right and and
generally they will say oh it's someone
from the upper mid levels of a great big
successful company that we've all heard
of what I've learned and it took me to
to go rounds to learn this by the way is
that that is almost a disqualifier to be
a good present company I need I need a
guy with an MBA telling me what to do
like I need a hole in the head I
don't like right like what like oh my
god I so I I've had a I got lucky I've
had a lot of great success we have a guy
Adam Ryan who's our president and I've
known him since high school I'm from
Missouri so I'm not from like this fancy
San Francisco stuff like I live now and
that was awesome because Adam has
wonderful at being scrappy and things
like this but he also can be like a big
company suit
if you wanted to and what I found is and
I've hired some MBAs and it didn't work
out what I found is these gray hair
they're not actually great hair but it's
more figurative these best practices
this
they just these people can't roll with
the punches and I never had success with
that test
I've hired I have a few businesses on
this like little investments I've made
and we've hired CEOs who are like this
and it just man it never works any but
you think that it should yeah well it's
it's a little bit akin to trying to get
a cat to bark exactly a path yeah dogs
bark so saying that well you know either
one of them should be able to do this
thing is just not right and you wouldn't
do it because it would be preposterous
and yet what people do all the time
especially institutional investors make
this mistake they assume that because
somebody operated out of scale right and
at a successful brand that well that
person clearly can this will be easy for
person and it's it's almost the
reciprocal because what what they don't
realize or haven't thought through is
those people are playing a different
game like Michael Jordan was you know
arguably the best basketball player in
history when he went over to the major
league baseball ready hit with a thud
why he's a great athlete he's playing a
different sport so so what works for
women on the basketball court you know
doesn't work when you're on the mound of
a baseball diamond and and so I think
it's the very similar thing big company
big company leaders have large staffs
generally a lot of certainty in the
direction that they're heading you know
kind of single-digit management
objectives right up or down
it's it's it's a in a very long patient
bureaucratic decision making process
yeah you're almost more like a
politician you're a politician a little
bit you're not yeah consists of a small
company right a small company and by
that I mean anything south of 100
million bucks is it's constantly
pivoting and in the the windows
to make those pivots or not you know
years
you're not even quarters you know you're
lucky if they're months and so though I
think the difference in the operating
cadence and style is profound and just
going to a big company a successful big
company manager and thinking they're
gonna be successful as a small company
president it almost never works out yeah
I think that look if once it once my
business becomes a financial arbitrage
machine and I need someone to figure out
how to milk out three percent off the
bottom line by using less materials then
I'm gonna get one of those nerds but
until then I need innovative people who
understand how to eat it's a perfect
balance of art and science who
understand like financial analysis and
things like that but who also can
understand what motivates buyers and who
can think of widgets that you know make
people feel good and want to purchase
and be it's just I've been to this so I
empathize you uh are you investing in
anything at the moment or 100 percent of
your time on this or like on Saturdays
and Sundays are you tinkering with
anything totally outside of this field
perpetually yes yeah right now well I
mean there's a lot of different things
that interest me I'm you know I'm an
angel investor in a bunch of different
enterprises both inside and outside of
health and fitness and I because I'm a
super you know I'm a startup nerd so I I
live and breathe you know that and I
teach I teach classes at both my alma
mater is at the Marshall school USC and
at the Graduate School Business at
Stanford so I get to see a ton of Liam
badass so you're a fitness guy a Navy
SEAL and academic you know I have to put
that in quotes Sam I'm not sure that I
would that I would put academic
technically I'm right though be you tell
you dude you teach at Stanford ok what
I'm a lecturer right not a professor so
so that means that you had all you had
to do is have gone there and then I've
done
something that didn't suck subsequently
right and made a list you're just an
eclectic dude you'll like you can kick
someone's ass but then also like you
talk to them about Aristotle and like
Britain's economic policy now the impact
of imperialism then I think I'm at that
part right right I'm gonna collective
dude and I'm I'm a super geeky inventor
you know which which I love I mean I've
got like 40 patents that I didn't care
less about the patents what I cared
about was the thing right like bringing
the thing to life and then once you do
particularly in today's digital economy
but you gotta protect it because if you
don't you'll be knocked off and blown
out of you know blown into oblivion
almost immediately with factory direct
stores out of China that have FBA shops
on Amazon now so you know so that's why
I became you know like I joke about
having a minor PhD in intellectual
property law that I never wanted but I
had to learn and so all of that like all
the nuts and bolts of creating and then
you know articulating a vision and and
wrangling a team to to to share that
vision and then moving that thing
forward that's the stuff that that makes
my you know my heart pound what are your
best angel investments well I mean I
suppose we'll wait and see until they
until they they pan out but yeah uh no
not yet I'm sort of an equity investor
right I'm I'm you know I make a good
living now and and so I'm not you know
I'm not I'm not in any of these for a
quick turn but I think that they all
will and you know most of them are in
areas that I that I I tend to to both
invest and advise only in things that I
think I can make a difference in I've
taken a couple of different fliers on on
things that you know buddies that I
trust and our domain experts in other
areas have said hey man you should get
in on this you know but I'm and also
let's just qualify this I'm a small you
know investor all I'm not I'm not
placing six-figure investments one after
and
but I but I I tend to invest in things
where I can help the operating team
based on my own experience try and
really experience is just the sum of all
your mistakes as much as anything else
and so I you know I can help early-stage
businesses set up their their
partnership arrangements right figure
out what makes a good partner figure out
what capital sources that make the most
sense for them or because I know both
the pros and the cons of all of them at
this point and then you know team
selection that's I mean I've been
leading teams since I was you know 22
year old frogman and led all the way up
to you know the national level and so
I've got a lot of experience whether
I've done all right I certainly haven't
haven't done all wrong either but I've
got a lot of experience in in helping
you know build a culture create team
dynamics that are that are durable and
and performance oriented and build
brands so if it's in those categories
that's kind of my wheelhouse I have to
polish real thing I go in the restroom
real quick go we'll edit this part out
sorry about that
no no man yeah are you an MMA fan yeah
big-time so I'm a huge MMA fan and I
this quarantine thing I've gotten very
healthy much like I've done higher
Mane's and things like that but I've
like actually started using my TRX by
the way and there you go lifting weights
I've gotten strong but I I have a weight
loss challenge and I have $500 on the
line and I have to hit it by Saturday
and I have I'm gonna crush it just
through diet and exercise but I began
just I'm drinking like crazy amounts of
water because I want to do like a MMA
weight cut and just like destroy the
benchmark oh yeah and so I'm uh I'm
currently drinking three gallons of
water a day and then tomorrow and the
next day I'm gonna taper down my goal is
to crush everyone that's great yeah I've
been an MMA fan since before there was
MMA because you know coming up in the
SEAL Teams right you do a it was very
eclectic in terms of the the coaches
that we would bring in so I I was a you
know I've been the the full gamut I was
I was an MMA guy before MMA was turned
right everybody was still purists in
there arts but because I had this
Bedouin lifestyle of constantly
deploying and coming back I didn't have
that luxury so I became you know I'd
been a kickboxer and a wrestler in high
school kickboxer through college then a
then a got into jutsu at the end of
college and and lean into that you know
hard in as a seal but it was never I
never had the luxury of being in one
place for more than a couple years at a
time and and so but I've been a huge fan
of we did a ton of sponsorship actually
of the fighters in the UFC
prior to Reebok buying the you know the
global rights to to the sponsorship
placements so yeah I in fact Mike Dolce
could
should help you with your with your
weight cut right he's a he's a freaking
master that's death
well so we do you know do you know who
Ben Askren is sure I've become friends
with been through this podcast and media
and so he's been helping me out and
name-dropping a little but I'm a huge
fan of his and then I start talking to
him like it's awesome I'm principal I
looked up to and then I think we're
having Michael Bisping come on and do a
podcast as well yeah they're great
man I mean a screms a stud wrestler and
biz beings just you know you talk about
one of the veterans of the of the sport
I was so happy when you know when he
finally got to the mountaintop after all
those years of racial fighting everybody
that you know that was that was there to
be fought and he just kept sort of
somehow falling just short but he
finally got there before retirement so I
was stoked for him so you um you know
about all this stuff and it's sometimes
whenever I talk about like MMA and UFC
I'm like I think I'm being too niche
right now no one cares I think it's way
bigger than I actually realized but when
you were in the seals this the seal
thing interests me for two reasons one
Jaco wilt is it Willick yeah sure
willing well link that guy's everywhere
right now so and he's always fun and
he's got good clips that are fun to
watch and then I'm also reading David
Goggins book can't hurt me
yeah it randomly came up on my audible
thing and I started listening to it it's
it's emotional it's sad it's hard to
listen to have you looked have you heard
it well I mean I know I know David you
know I did never work together but I you
know you cross paths same thing with
Jocko those guys are those guys are both
way behind me in terms of age but the
and so and the SEAL Teams you know if if
somebody's more than a couple of years
ahead or behind you the the likelihood
of you knowing him is possible but not
high unless you worked at the same
places right in which case then you then
you transcend the age barriers because
you're all you know at a command
together and you you work together and I
never work with either one of those guys
in fact I think as I was getting out
they were both coming in but I
certainly no you know of both of them
and I like what what they both done with
their brands and you know Jocko has done
some really really cool stuff with his
podcast and his other appearances in
fact he popped up the other day on on
the billions which I was laughing about
oh I haven't watched through the
premiere and a few up so this new the
new season he popped up in that and I
was like yeah man that's what I love it
when I see other frogs doing doing good
stuff versus stupid where they're
out there you know telling and selling
secrets that are gonna you know put
other guys at risk which I do not admire
but I but I really love when I see guys
out there doing great things post career
because that's what the whole country is
supposed to be predicated on right it's
the citizen soldier you've come in you
serve for however long you try to serve
as well as you can and then you go on
and do something something else cool out
in the civilian community and be able to
share some of the things you learned I
love that Jocko does that and I love the
Dave's doing that as well so when I
started my business I I was like like
you or I'm just like I like to invent
things and I like selling them and I
like making money what I didn't was what
I always did track-and-field and running
and weightlifting and swimming and those
are all individual sports and what I
really struggled with early on was how
to be a leader it's super hard because
you like for a lot of people they start
stuff because it's like I said it's fun
and it makes money and it's cool
they don't but then they like if it was
successful then they're like oh I got to
be like a leader of men and women not
necessarily a creator of products what
do you think do you think that I mean I
know the answer the answer is definitely
yes but what specifically helped being
in the seals in terms of business
leadership and managing a team and by
the way how many people do you have
we've got about a hundred full timers
and then we we you know we use another
350 master instructors to deliver our
education courses so they're 1099s but
you know so it 100 full-time plus or
minus and you know another several
hundred that we need to we employ as
contractors do you think people would
say you're a good manager and or or
a good leader I think they'd probably
say I'm a better leader than I am a
manager right that's that would be my
guess because it maps to I mean I can
manage and I the distinction between
that to me is quite a wide gap right
there are there are people I think who
can do both at a very high level but not
many because the I believe that most of
the characteristics that make someone
really good at one or the other
almost prevent you from being good at
both I mean there are some extraordinary
people I think out there that can do
both but but management requires just a
a different level of you know attention
to - - minutiae I want to say detail
because I'm very detail-oriented but
ongoing minutiae which is important in
making a business go um you know I don't
have the patience for it and I also you
know I never I never really liked
corporate management I I liked
leadership a lot and leadership is about
storytelling being authentic right
motivating and communicating and you
think you're good at that I mean you
seem very charismatic do you think
they're a good leader yeah I think
that's one of the strengths that I have
developed largely as as a result of my
experience in the SEAL Teams what
doesn't think I can learn from you then
through your field experience and that
our listeners can learn anything well I
mean we do you know so I do I do a key I
do a keynote that is pretty massively
oversubscribed frankly called lessons of
a frogman
and it's leadership lessons a business
leadership lessons that I learned as a
seal which turns out almost all of the
key lessons that I know I actually
learned as a seal the leadership lessons
not necessarily the tactical business
lessons but and and you know you would
think and I actually had one of the
assistant Dean's at Stanford Business
School when I was out interviewing for
two to be accepted there you know give
me this sort of patron
and put a shoulder hand on my shoulder
and basically said well that you know
why do you want it what do you think we
should take you Randy I talked about you
know my leadership experience you know I
was at that point I was at the special
missions unit as a as a troop commander
and had been in the SEAL Teams for you
know out of ten years or so and you know
then he put his hand on my shoulder and
said well then it's it's a bit different
leading in the real world than it is in
the military don't don't don't you think
because out here you can't just tug on
your collar device and have everyone
snap to and do what you say i don't livi
it i was so astonished man i was like is
this guy for real right now or is he
baiting me and and i basically said to
him you know uh dean if that's your view
on military leadership that i think it
says a lot more about how little you
know than it does about the subject of
leadership and you know not surprising
that i didn't get in that time but but
but you know i think that if you're
talking about people and groups of
people there are many many more
commonalities to how to lead and
motivate the group then there are
differences depending on you know like
irrespective of domain because you're
talking about anthropological behavior
and that changes very slowly over
millennia you know and whether you're a
you know a baker or a freakin frontline
soldier or a software developer if
you're dealing with other people humans
behave
you know largely the same way they have
different micro cultures but but we're
all part of the Homo Sapien species and
we we've evolved our behaviors over you
know hundreds of thousands if not
millions of years so the commonalities
are that people want to be inspired they
want to be they want to associate with
something they believe in and other
people you share that belief system they
want to feel important right like
they're contributing everyone wants
approval and reinforcement that what
we're doing is is
good and so figuring out how in a
context to provide those basic human
needs is what leadership is all about
and and I think that it's not actually
very domain-specific whereas management
arguably is much more domain-specific
right depending on the industry and and
I think that requires you know a
different set of skills and very often
the things that makes them one a good
manager prevent them from wanting to be
on the podium prevent them from wanting
to take risks right and and those are
things that you know you can't lead
anybody if you're not willing to get on
point and and so I think that you know
leading and managing or related but not
same thing as this lessons of a frogman
is that available publicly if I google
that can I watch it I hope not because
it's one of the is it's one of the you
know the side hustles that I enjoy doing
I actually it's obviously I'm doing them
during covert 19 but but I'm I'm working
on a couple of books in the early stages
one of them is is going to be that it's
gonna be the deeper look into the
substance of my you know keynotes that I
do for corporations the other is is
gonna be an entrepreneur Survival Guide
because what I discovered right is that
the gap between what I learned at
Stanford Business School and the stuff I
actually needed the day I launched this
scrappy little strapped startup couldn't
have been wider right and and that's at
one of the best business schools in the
world but what it what those business
schools really prepare you to do is
enter as a mid-level manager into a
large organization very few of them
prepare you to be a boot scrape
entrepreneur right that needs to walk
out and figure out how to how to find
some space how to get pesky little
things like insurance you know when you
when you start thinking about somebody
you're gonna partner with what's that
all about
you know how do you go about the nuts
and bolts of raising money without
screwing yourself you know there and
ever after all that stuff you don't
really get in Business School you get
that by getting out there and doing
you know hope so no I agree and we're
gonna be wrapping up soon so I want to
ask you just I wanted to wrap up the
questions on angel investing any
companies that you've written checks to
that we would know about well I mean I
can tell you a couple of ones that I'm
super excited about right now there's
there's one of my ironically one of my
board members started a company called
basil Street Cafe which is a really cool
automated Pizza Kitchen concept that I
think co19 has has actually now made
more viable even than before but it's a
really sophisticated combination of
technology branding and distribution to
create a nationwide initially and then
global automated Pizza Kitchen and and
that produces some of the most kick-ass
pizza that I've ever had in my life
which is really astonishing because your
expectations have a machine or very low
and it turns out it's every bit as good
or better than blaze or any restaurant
quality pizza so that Softbank backed
one of those automated pizza companies
hopefully you guys have a better a
better run at it than those guys I think
sometimes you know like there are things
that that you know we're a great idea
but we're ahead of their time and I
think some of the some of the plays that
have attempted to do this before had an
interesting idea but the technology they
didn't get right and you know and it's
largely a distribution business as well
because you have to make great great
pizza and be able to you know keep the
keep the machines stocked with it and so
it's a but I'm excited about that one
you know I've got another buddy that I'm
helping that has a company called ever
ins
which i think is a really cool you know
opposite end of the spectrum and a lot
of in a lot of respects it's it's
basically a very unique way to to
collect capture and then encapsulate can
be anything but the idea is hair ash
could be any kind of material you know
from a flower from you know the
mountaintop where you got married or
buried your gran
mother or whatever and then enables that
to then be put into either jewelry right
that that you now have for instance I'm
having some stuff done right now that
I'll have my boys you know lakhs of
their hair encapsulated and put into a
bracelet right that'll happen with me
always
and so it's like with Billy Bob Thornton
and Angelina Jolie had filed the blood
you ever read about that they're
weirdo but the other thing they do
that's really interesting you you choose
to put it into jewelry or into tattoos
so for everybody who has tattoos and
wants to ascribe a little more meaning
to them right it's a it's kind of a cool
thing to be a MacRay to cut a lock of
you know everything from your dog's hair
to your kids hair or a cheek swab and
you send it off to them and they've got
this patented unique process what the
call into what what you know keepsake
basically a permanent keepsake with a
jewelry or a tattoo
how do you spell it Everett's e ve R and
C E and they're cool they're website
severance dot life but yeah there's a
couple you know that and and then I'm
involved in a in a technology company
and lidar radar called lumen R which is
a cool a cool company and that's one of
the example of one of those that all
right not exactly in my wheelhouse right
not an area that I can necessarily add
value to but you know very exciting and
another friend who pays a lot closer
attention to that space you know put it
in front of me and it just made sense
it's it's you know one of the companies
that's out there vying for supremacy in
the self-driven
automobile category and I feel like if
you if you tell me that category and
that you're starting a company in there
I would just invest in there just
because it's like yeah probably right
it's kind of in that category and then
you look at that you look at the you
know the leaders and go well those
people are really smart people this is
us this is a sector someone's gonna win
in probably more than one so you know
reasonable and again as I said you know
I'm I'm uh I'm a you know 20 to 50 K
investor in any given one thing I'm not
taking huge exposed positions usually I
like to invest in things where you know
I can help based on my experience as a
brand or as an entrepreneur you know
some government stuff that I've got
involved with because obvious I spent a
long time and you know in the government
space but and then just some cool
companies right there's cool companies
that I'm trying to help right now like
in d.com is an awesome new platform to
help influencers monetize their
followings right with content and I'm a
big believer in that space and it's in
it's an area where I can help them by
exposing them to our large installed
base of trainers who all of whom are
influencers in their own right and
trying to figure out how to scale
themselves right and create new sort of
passive streams of income so you know
it's a smattering right and and there's
you know there's a handful of others
that are kind of in the same same
category were you able to get some
liquidity from the first PE event in
order to make these investments the
first one no I should have right and
that's one of the I mean one of the big
lessons for anybody who's listening and
I really believe this unfortunately I
didn't I didn't hear it or or if I heard
it I didn't listen the first time I
heard it but I really think for
entrepreneurs you really should not with
I'm speaking generally because there are
exceptions to every you know every
generality but in general I don't think
entrepreneurs should take institutional
capital without pulling a significant
piece off the table it just you know
from the time that you do and you
introduce a preferred class of shares
into your cap stack things change right
what would be your definition of
significant a million five million five
hundred thousand I think it depends on
the venture I I would view I would view
it from where I sit now as you know if
you were building and then running a
successful company that and you thought
that the only option for financing was
to go raise it
institutions I sell at least 1/3 you
know of of my holding to bring those
people in enough basically enough to be
ok if things go differently than you
expected that that would be sort of the
you know the rule of thumb ant answer so
that we've had a wait but you had a way
for the second round then to make that
happen
yeah yeah and and you know I probably
could have sold more at the first stop
but I I was very bullish and very you
know as entrepreneurs need to be and I
thought hey this is you know I'm not
selling anything right now
um and that you know that was a big
mistake that when I look back on it
later on on it you don't realize it you
could be locked up with these guys for a
long time right and once they're in
front of you then getting any kind of
liquidity becomes really problematic so
you know that's just something that
entrepreneurs need to keep in mind and
you know you could you could lose
control obviously if you sell control
but there are other ways where you know
through the Preferences that
institutional investors tend to get into
term sheets where your autonomy and your
ability to drive the bus at the very
least get impaired in ways that you
didn't expect and you didn't have the
ability and we'll wrap this up a second
what you didn't have the ability to take
a couple million bucks like a million
dollars off the profit each year to pay
yourself I mean so like you are just
strictly earning a low salary as the
company grew or were you able to like
because if you raise five million bucks
right out the gate I would imagine you
wouldn't even have had the ability to
say like well this year we made three
million in profit I'm gonna write myself
a seven hundred thousand dollar check no
of course not and and you don't you know
and that's not frankly that's I mean
that's that's a tough way for an
early-stage entrepreneur to even think
because if you're starting to think
about trying to extract stuff out of an
early stage business chances are you're
gonna impair that businesses growth and
so my my view is never of that I mean I
wanted to start making money right
because the first
if you count you know two years of
Business School where I was where I was
working on this idea I went the first
that those two years blessed the next
three without any pay right so I was
five years you know into a no pay
environment baseline and that's why I'm
saying like but you're like ten years in
before you raise the first round I think
right yeah we were maybe a little less
time a were nine years in don't think by
that point like alright if we're doing
okay like I could definitely I can
definitely work I should have taken
money off the table then that was one of
the mistakes right because what I
focused on instead was hey I want you
know to up my up my my salary right and
my bonus structure to a point at which I
can start making you know a good living
on an annual basis but I should have I
should have done both right because that
that was possible and I chose to just
focus on all right let's get my cash
comp up to a up to a level that feels
right for you know what I've built in
the hundred hours a week that I'm
working and not worry so much about you
know extracting value right now right oh
man you're saying you should have it
just increase your salary and bonuses
not I should have done both is what I
said I I did increase my salary and
bonus structure I did not pull money out
of the business right and that we're
gonna stake all were you paying yourself
that to where I mean we paying 50 grand
a year well I mean no probably more than
that by by then but early on yeah I mean
should for the first three years I was
paying myself nothing then I think I
started paying myself 50 grand you know
and it just sort of if you if you dollar
cost average back you know it would have
been a very bad financial decision right
on an on an hourly basis but you know
you get there and and I make you know a
good living today that's that's that's
plenty so you know it all evens out but
if you dollar cost average the first ten
years I probably made fifty grand a year
you know which which after 14 years as a
Navy SEAL with a Stanford MBA right
eight killing it and
in Mill Valley where I lived in San
Francisco at the time I thought the
alley like everyone does eventually or
to Marin you know but but yeah I was
living in you know living the city
paying a mortgage up on Twin Peaks and
oh no I'm in Glen Park oh well
that's that's where I was I was right
behind tower market Austin Park my Glen
Park was my my my rake dealer you know
the Chenery rest strong I was still down
no but that was my rage and I live it
down the hill and you know you Glen okay
I live in Park
I rang Glen Canyon today and I have a
house here with like a garage and a gym
with my TRX this is awesome man you're
cool I appreciate you taking the
time what's your preferred method what's
your preferred method of chatting with
people to Twitter that rainy hat trick
ride Instagram Instagram and on Facebook
at TRX training is is the brand and TRX
training calm is is obviously our
website I'm working on a Randy Hetrick
calm website right now we're where some
of my stuff that you know my next big
big vision is to to take a page out of
Richard Branson's you know handbook and
and basically figure out ways to grow my
brand that can help the brand that I
gave birth to do things that maybe it
can do and vice versa right you ladder
yourselves up just like he's done with
virgin and the Richard Branson brand
that's that's you know sort of a goal
that I have maybe you know I'd be wildly
fortunate to get to his scale but I
could I could be happy with a lot less
than that scale as long as I'm still
contributing value to with the
mothership and it's giving me
opportunities to do cool stuff
well I I think you you you look you you
have the story you have the look you
have the charisma Navy SEAL who's fit
and also went to Stanford IV yeah
[Music]